oops
good afternoon everyone i'd like to
welcome you
as well as our good friends from c-span
to the mcgowan theatre located in the
national archives building here in
washington d.c
i'm doug swanson visitor services
manager for the national archives museum
as well as the producer for the noontime
lecture series
before we begin today's program i just
like to remind you of a few other
programs we've got coming up in the near
future
on thursday march 16th at 7 p.m damien
shields will present a lecture on the
forgotten irish
irish immigrant experiences in america
this will be the u.s
book launch of the book and there will
be a book signing following
then on wednesday march 22nd at 7 pm
we'll present a film screening and
discussion of following seas which is
presented in partnership with the dc
environmental film festival
to find out more about these and our
other programs please take one of our
monthly calendar of events which you'll
find in the racks in the theater lobby
or you can visit our website at
www.archives.gov
calendar
our topic for today is agent 110
american spymaster and the german
resistance in world war ii by scott
miller
scott miller is an author and former
foreign correspondent for the wall
street journal his first book the
president and the assassin mckinley
terror and the empire at the dawn of the
american century was a newsweek magazine
must read summer selection as a
journalist miller spent nearly two
decades in asia and europe reporting for
more than 20 i'm sorry reporting from
more than 25 countries including two
postings in germany
which
the backdrop which is his backdrop for
agent 110
he has appeared on the daily show with
john stewart national geographic channel
cnbc and britain sky news he also holds
degrees in economics and communications
and earn a master of philosophy in
international relations from the
university of cambridge
please join me in welcoming scott miller
to the national archives
thanks doug
i thought
what i would do today is talk a little
bit about kind of the background behind
this book how i came to write it
introduce you to some of the characters
along the way
and then describe a little bit about
sort of the final product and then we'll
have time for questions and
any comments that you have afterwards
i will readily confess that i did not
set out to write this book
i was originally very interested in the
early days of americans involvement in
the vietnam war
that whole period it was always
held an interest for me
um you know really right after the war
the
french involvement in indochina
and it also seemed like a subject that
hadn't been done to death already
so i began to do a little bit of
research
and i happened to cross these two
characters
there they are
those are the dulles brothers
alan dulles is in the lighter colored
jacket
he was director of the cia
during the 50s and during the period i
was interested in
and the gentleman in the dark suit is
his older brother john foster dulles who
was secretary of state
when i found these two guys i thought
boy there's got to be an interesting
story here
it's an interesting time in american
history there's two brothers and i
thought there's got to be a
sort of a good relationship there's got
to be some good way of telling that
story so i really dove in
and i discovered pretty quickly that
alan the guy in the light colored jacket
had been in switzerland during world war
ii where he was a station chief
for the office of strategic services and
there he was given code number 110
and immediately my interest kind of
perked up i've always been a little bit
of a world war ii geek
and probably more importantly i've
always been a frustrated ski bum
and
we lived in germany where i was a
newspaper correspondent and pretty much
every weekend that we could we'd head
down to switzerland and hit the slopes
and the thought of doing a book that
took place in switzerland sort of really
captured my imagination
alan
also became a very interesting figure
for me he was born to a very patrician
american family he had two relatives who
were secretaries of state
he had served in the state department
early in his career he'd quit that job
to make more money and went to wall
street so he got a law degree and worked
at the law firm sullivan and cromwell
and i really kind of got interested in
the kind of the idea of the gentleman
spy he had a very little bit of
espionage experience when he was sent
off for really what was a big job in
switzerland
so at that point kind of my focus began
to shift and i thought maybe there's a
story really just to do with what alan
was up to in world war ii but i still
needed a lot more information and i was
particularly particularly concerned and
interested to find out
what sort of sort of subordinate
characters there might be that would
help round out the story
very quickly i discovered
there's a picture of allen in
switzerland you can see the alps in the
background and looks like you've got a
tennis court there he's accompanied by
his number two in the oss bureau
very quickly i discovered this woman
that's mary bancroft
now mary came from the same sort of
family that dulles did she was from
boston
her father had been publisher of the
wall street journal
she'd married a american figure skating
champion who competed in the 1928
olympics
but um she left him for what she
described as a purely physical
attraction to another man
and it turned out that mary had a real
eye for the gentleman
and
she ended up meeting a swiss fella by
the name of jean rufenacht
and they moved to switzerland
she admitted that she didn't really love
jean but she was really interested in
his personal story at least the story
that he told her
gene claimed that he was part turkish
it was entirely a lie he did it just to
get mary's attention and mary loved sort
of the sense of danger and adventure
that she imagined turkish people
entailed and so they ended up getting
married and they moved to switzerland
where mary sort of threw herself into
swiss society she had a very outgoing
and extroverted personality i think
there was at times a little bit of spark
with her neighbors um you know the sort
of reserved swiss
weren't uh the sort that immediately
took to her
but she
soon met there's a picture of mary in
switzerland
she met a lot of notable people
including the famed psychiatrist carl
jung
and she met jung when she developed a
sort of weird
sort of affliction and whereby she would
start sneezing when she was in socially
awkward situations
and so she took this to jung who was
able to cure her and she was very much
impressed by jung
also i think she developed a little bit
of a crush on him
she left a quote where she said that
she fell in one hell of an attractive
guy
and she kind of wormed her way into a
group of people who spent a lot of time
with jung and began to study his work
she became pretty well known especially
among americans in switzerland and they
recruited her pretty early when they saw
that war was coming to do various jobs
kind of state department jobs looking at
german speeches and writing them up
writing newspaper articles that were
favorable to the american government
when dulles arrived they introduced her
to dulles
and he immediately asked her to join his
team and she came to
sort of assume a fairly important role
in what dulles was doing
and then
very suitable for my purposes and
telling a good story she became dulles
mistress
and
so i thought you know here's a here's a
good character
she brings a lot of dimension to the
story and
really flushes it out
then i kept looking and i came across
this guy
and that's hans behrend gazavius
now he's a german
he's a bit of a hulk of a man he stood
six foot four
everybody who knew him describing as
being insufferably arrogant and
difficult to deal with
he had risen through the german security
and police services and he'd been in the
gestapo in the very early days
his career in the gestapo didn't go very
well he was a real schemer and a plotter
and he decided that he could advance his
career by spreading a rumor about the
head of the gestapo he told people that
he thought he was a communist
now that didn't go over very well um
because xavius got drummed out of the
gestapo and was actually lucky that he
wasn't thrown in jail
but he was able to land a job in another
arm of the german intelligence services
called the abvare
and this was a group that they basically
did intelligence for the german military
and gazebos attitudes toward the germans
and towards the nazis
was rapidly changing at this point
in the gestapo he had seen how nasty the
nazis could be
and i think also of course he would
never admit it and i'm just
my supposing here but
i sure get the feeling that he was just
kind of
pissed off that his career hadn't gone
as well as he hoped
and so he began to plot against the uh
the nazis
they sent him to switzerland
where he immediately uh reached out to
the british who were very skeptical of
skeptical of him
and he tried to establish contact with
the americans who were also pretty
worried i mean he was not a very
trustworthy guy
um
at best he was a double agent and you
don't really want to put a lot of
confidence in somebody like that but he
quickly met dulles and dulles was
willing to meet him
and they developed a good relationship
now for me this was perfect aside from
these two characters what was really
good was that both of them survived the
war
and that they wrote about their
experiences
mary
wrote an autobiography which was
published in the 80s
she left unpublished versions of it at
radcliffe university including her
diaries and all sorts of really valuable
information
xavius
two wrote an autobiography he worked on
it during the war
and what made it really interesting was
that uh it turned out that mary helped
him write it
she was the fact that she did so was one
of dulles schemes he wanted to learn as
much as he could about gazavious and so
working with mary he asked her to help
him
translate the book and to work on bits
and pieces of it
and so
he produced a
very it wasn't entirely accurate in
places but it was an insightful account
of what it was like to work with dulles
and so at this point i thought okay
there's good characters there's a good
story it's a good time i just have to
figure out kind of what the narrative
thread is what's the what's the plot to
this book there were lots of great
anecdotes and spy stories but i felt
like they didn't really link
so at first i tried
looking at dulles and typically towards
the soviets and
as you might remember at this time
the united states was an ally of the
soviet union and they were supposed to
be our friends
but dulles didn't buy it and he spent a
lot of the war warning the united states
and anybody who would listen that the
servant the soviets weren't to be
trusted and they really were aiming to
dominate europe after the war
so i wrote actually some of the book
along those lines
and i showed it to my editor
who thought you know that's a good idea
but
maybe there's a better one looking at
the activities of the resistance
and i sort of did what any good author
or journalist would do when the editor
makes a suggestion i immediately thought
you know surely that can't be true if it
was if it was good i would have thought
of it by now
it turned out my editor was dead right
there was a really good story to tell
with the resistance and best of all the
story of the resistance really sort of
moved and dovetailed
very closely with what delos did and
dulles worked with him so that really
sort of led us to the book that
the book that we have now
there's a picture of dulles taken about
this time
he always had the pipe with him
everybody always talked about that
dulles
arrived in switzerland in november 1941
or 1942 rather
his cover
and every everybody had some sort of
cover he traveled under his real name
and everybody knew that it was alan
dulles
but his official explanation for being
in switzerland was that he was a special
assistant to the american
mission the american head of mission in
barron
he claimed and i think probably
correctly so that he was the last
american to enter switzerland before the
germans sealed off the border
and he was really in a lot of ways
maroon there during the war he couldn't
leave for several years
he wasn't able to receive much help from
the oss a few agents were able to sneak
through
from italy but he didn't have a great
deal of interaction with them
so it was sort of a bit difficult for
him this is the house that he selected
he lived on the first floor which also
served as his office
and he chose this particular location
this picture was taken i think around
1933
and it's in the old quarter of baron on
a street called the heron gasa
and he chose it specifically because
there was a busy shopping street on sort
of other end of the heron grass
hirangasa so there was a lot of foot
traffic going back and forth and he
figured that would provide cover for
people who were coming to visit him
there at the uh at the front door he
occasionally saw what he suspected were
german agents across the street
monitoring the comings and goings
even better was that this house you
can't see it in this picture but the
backyard
slopes down gently towards a river
and it was covered with a vineyard
and a lot of his contacts would come up
by night he turned off the lights and
they would come up through the cover of
the vineyard to knock at the back door
and he was able to meet a lot of people
that way without anybody who was
monitoring the front knowing what he was
up to
dulles arrived in switzerland some with
some contacts he'd been in the
uh in the american diplomatic corps and
in the legal profession he knew some
people and he was able to look him up
right off the bat and
found out some interesting things
but it was really going to be a pretty
slow slog to build up the kind of
network that
he wanted to achieve
so he employed a couple of techniques
one was simply to buy intelligence
dulles bragged to everybody about how
well financed he was
um
and word quickly got around baron which
was a very small town particularly among
the the diplomatic and and spy community
a british
agent
once remarked that dulles may as well
have put a sign on the front door that
said intelligence purchased here
another
technique that dulles employed
was to simply meet everybody who came
along you know normally
somebody is setting up a spy ring a
station chief would show some discretion
before he would meet somebody
trying to feel them out and find out if
they were going to feed him bogus
information or if they were even
dangerous
but not dulles
and this is from a lesson that he had
learned during world war one
he had been in barren
[Music]
one sunday afternoon he was in the
american mission there and the phone
rang and somebody called up and said uh
you know i really need to talk to an
american diplomat
now dulles loved to play tennis
and he loved young ladies and that
afternoon he had a tennis state with an
attractive one
so he said i'm busy you know call back
on monday
and dulles later learned that the person
who called that day was vladimir lenin
and he never learned what lenin had to
say
but it was a lesson that he took very
much to heart and he talked about that
throughout his career about the
importance of not prejudging anybody
so with that dulles was able to sort of
rapidly get to know people and kind of
applying his lenin principle
it enabled him to meet
this guy
i'm sorry the picture is a little bit
has some imperfections his family gave
it to me
and it's you know got a little bit of
wear and tear over the years
that is fritz kolbe
he was a german member of the foreign
ministry he had kind of a low-level
position he was essentially kind of a
clerk
but by the end of the war he became what
was probably america's most important
intelligence
asset during the entire war
he was
a dedicated anti-nazi and an
anti-bolshevik and i think he also
had a real taste for adventure he liked
the idea of being a spy
and so um
his position offered him an opportunity
to see a lot of top secret german
documents um
the german all three branches of the
german military would update the foreign
ministry with what they were doing and
he had an opportunity to read these
documents and kind of decide what was
passed on to who
so he started coming into the foreign
ministry on sundays when it was quiet
and everybody was at home
and he would take notes on these top
secret documents
in almost
unreadable handwriting and you can
imagine the stress he was under probably
writing as rapidly as he could
and he started collecting these
documents but he really didn't have
anybody to give them to
uh um he had a friend in switzerland who
at one point
reached out to the brits who
weren't interested the
the british had recently been fooled by
a similar offer and they've lost two
agents
and this looked like
you know a similar
ruse and they were not going to fall for
it
so
coba was able to make contact with
dulles
shortly after dulles arrived they had a
midnight meeting in an apartment in
bayern
and dulles was at first skeptical
but colba produced about 180 documents
on that particular day including ones
that describe german codes
he talked about a german agent that was
operating in ireland
and one of the coolest things was a map
of hitler's headquarters on the eastern
front
and he sketched it out that evening for
dulles just on a little piece of paper
and said here's where hitler holds his
briefings here's the railroad tracks
here's the theater you know the whole
thing and you can see that little piece
of paper at the national archives up in
college park
it's really cool
by the end of the war he supplied the
u.s with about
i think 2 000 documents
and undertook tremendous risks and you
know despite um
having zero training and intelligence
and
transporting these documents back and
forth to between berlin and
switzerland he originally he tied the
copies he made copies and he just simply
tied them around his leg with twine
under his pants to get him to
switzerland he later developed more
sophisticated um techniques
but he ended up surviving and the nazis
never figured him out it was an amazing
accomplishment
what really got dulles
interest though
was
the stories that xavius told him about
the german resistance and the
underground
now at first dulles was quite suspicious
of gazavius the guy was a german agent
after all
that they were meeting together one
afternoon one evening actually and in
the haran gasa that we just saw the
heron gossa villa a couple of red
leather chairs that were in dulles
office and they were having a drink
and xavius reached into his pocket and
pulled out a little black book
and in this book or from it he read a
top secret american cable that had
recently been sent from switzerland
to washington
and there was no way that the germans
should have been able to get their hands
on this let alone been able to decipher
the code
and dulles couldn't believe it
and this is obviously very
revealing
and worrying information
[Music]
with this knowledge the americans
started using the the code they knew the
germans could read to send bogus
information to kind of confuse the
germans and of course they changed it
for their their real correspondence
but
the real importance of it was that
dulles came to really trust gazavious
the fact that you could read your
enemies codes was not something that you
gave away
so what
dulles learned from gazavious was that
there were two
fairly distinct resistance movements
operating in germany
one was led by members of the german
military
this rather
this guy despite his rather sour
expression
is ludwig beck
he had been the chief of staff of the
german army
until 1938 when he resigned in protest
over hitler's ambitious plans
he was he represented quite a number of
very senior german officers who were
opposed to hitler and wanted to do
something about it
he also learned that this character
carl gerdler who had been mayor of
leipzig was a member of this group
gordler was
an eternal optimist he kind of offset
the cold realism and sometimes the
negativity of the officer corps
he was probably too optimistic for his
own good he was a bit naive but did not
serve him well in the end
and members of the of this group also
worked most interestingly i think
with wilhelm canaris he's the guy he's
in the trench coat with sort of the fur
lining the shorter one there in the
center of the screen
and canaris was the head of the ob fair
the military intelligence
now he had started the war in the early
days and he was a hitler backer
like a lot of people were in the early
days because hitler was trying to
make up for the horrible treaty of
versailles
but as the war went along canaris really
learned to hate the nazis and he began
to use his position as head of the ob
there to plot against the nazis and
he carved out a number of important jobs
in the ob there for people who were
trying to overthrow hitler and hatching
plots against him
it was you know it's an amazing thing
here we are in the center of berlin the
center of their intelligence
and there's a little nest of people who
are trying to overthrow him
um it's really a remarkable story
dulles also learned that they're about
the second group
which was led by helmet james graf von
mulker
now if there's any sort of hardcore
military historians out there
you'll recognize molca as being a very
famous name in german military history
mulcah was a lawyer by training he
opposed the nazis from the earliest days
and he set up a group called the
chrysalis circle
this organization was very different
from
the group of officers they were younger
they were much more eclectic
there were journalists there were
members of the foreign ministry
academics
they were much more liberal they
initially had a lot of qualms about
whether it was morally right to kill
hitler maybe maybe an uh coup would be
okay but wasn't really morally
correct to actually murder somebody
they met in small cells around germany
and had discussions about what sort of
economy or political system germany
could have after the war one of the
really interesting things that they did
was they tried to avoid writing things
down for security purposes
but when they did they took them to
mulke's estate in the german countryside
and they hit them all in a special
compartment in a beehive
which i thought was a great place to
keep secret documents you can imagine
any police coming around taking a look
at a beehive and thinking
you know i'm sure that's fine
um
dulles learned something uh really
important from both these groups
and that was that they really wanted
american help
in deposing hitler
not so much in actually trying to kill
him or any secret operation but they
wanted a promise from the americans that
they would treat germany well after
there was a coup or after hitler had
been replaced
they all remembered how horrible it had
been after world war one and how
vindictive they felt the allies had been
towards germany
and they weren't going to risk their
necks
deposing hitler if it was going to be
doing the same thing all over again
dulles was
unable to offer those assurances
um and so the resistance did everything
they could to try and uh convince the
americans to uh you know their sincerity
they were very clever they started
initially by playing to dulles
well-known
hatred of the soviet union and they said
you know if the americans don't help us
i'm sure that moscow will
and they began to supply dulles with
information
that suggested that which is it was
legitimate but it certainly
served their needs
despite this the despite the fact that
the u.s wouldn't help them they
continued with their schemes and
probably there were several really
interesting attempts to knock off hitler
they came really close um hitler had an
amazing instinct for avoiding
assassination or avoiding a coup i mean
it's just incredible how many times
during the war he was able to escape
the resistance moved forward
towards a plot which was
hatched on july 20th 1944.
this is the
the famed valkyrie operation
it was led by sort of a relative
newcomer to the resistance klaus von
stauffenberg and he's on the far side of
this photo he's in the light color
jacket standing at attention
stauffenberg had always very much
opposed hitler and had decided the only
way to get rid of him was to murder him
and i don't know i won't go into it in
great depth unless you want to later on
because i think it's reasonably well
known there was a movie called valkyrie
a couple years ago with tom cruise
who actually bore quite a resemblance to
stauffenberg
hitler survived that attack as i said he
was injured and people were killed in it
but hitler survived
and what followed was really it was bad
for the resistance and it was bad for
hitler
and bad for dulles rather
in the weeks and months that followed
thousands of people were rounded up
around germany and hundreds were
executed
including all many members of dulles's
uh circle of informants
and for a time it really sort of didn't
look very good for dulles bancroft
talked about how
unhappy he was and the light had kind of
gone out of his life
he wasn't quite sure where it was all
heading
kind of by late 1944 he was receiving a
lot of surrender offer
from various
german officers or representatives of
them
and dallas really kind of dismissed
those they all looked pretty
self-serving you know attempts by people
to
sort of save their own neck
mandela's really kind of wondered what
would happen to his
his station
all that changed in the very first part
of 1945.
dulles was at home in the harengasa one
morning and he received a phone call
from a friend in swiss intelligence who
said that
carl wolf who was a general in the ss he
was in charge of the entire ss for italy
was then in switzerland and was on his
way to see dulles
now this was pretty shocking news um
wolf actually had with him a small
entourage of people
they had
reserved two cars on a regular swiss
passenger train and they pulled the
blinds down in both the cars so that
nobody could see him the uh
the trip didn't go particularly well on
that particular day an avalanche swept
down across the tracks
and
blocked his train he had to get out with
all the other members of the german team
march through the snow and get on a
regular swiss passenger train where they
risked being seen
but um he did succeed in seeing dulles
that night they met at a safe house that
the oss maintained in zurich
and wolf made a couple of startling
declarations to dulles
first that he was willing to surrender
the entire ss force in italy to dulles
which was that alone was pretty
tantalizing
but he also said that he was buddies
with
field marshal albert kessel ring
who was in charge of the german army in
italy
now this was pretty explosive stuff uh
they were talking about
the surrender of a million men
and the end of an entire front
and even more important from dulles and
the americans perspective was what it
meant for fighting in the alps
and in the closing stages of the war the
americans had convinced themselves
really entirely wrongly
that the germans were going to make a
last final stand in the mountains of
austria and italy
and there was lots of intelligence that
suggested that
the germans were building factories and
hollowing out tunnels and even building
air conditioning in some of these
factories there was a special commando
unit that was being established called
the werewolves
is a great name for a commando unit i
think
and as i said it turned out it was
completely wrong the intelligence was
bogus and the americans really fell for
a uh
uh kind of a pr scheme that joseph
goebbels
thought up
um but it really paralyzed american
thinking there the americans estimated
that if there was some sort of
um guerrilla war in the alps that it
could drag world war ii out by two more
years
and it promised to be very bloody
fighting all the advantages that the
american military enjoyed were kind of
nullified in the mountains
so when they saw an opportunity to
um
you know in the fighting in italy and
capture these troops or achieve their
surrender that was something that they
had to jump on
you can see in
this slide there's dulles and his number
two schultz of governance
looking at a map of italy
the only uh problem was that
the soviets found out pretty quickly
that dulles was talking to
senior german officers
and i think it's fair to say that
stalin pretty much blew a gasket
he had
spent the entire war worrying that the
u.s and britain would cut some sort of
secret deal with germany and that the
three of them would gang up on
him and this looked exactly like the
sort of thing that he had feared all
along
there were what followed were weeks of
bitter
uh transmissions between stalin and
roosevelt where stalin accused the
americans of operating behind their back
and roosevelt tried to calm him down but
roosevelt kind of got irritated and a
lot of historians kind of looked to
these exchanges as sort of the
beginnings of the cold war
another problem was that wolf grossly
oversold his position with dulles kessel
ring really was not interested in
surrendering in italy
and finally sort of most dangerous for
wolf was that heinrich himmler
the head of the ss in germany found out
that he'd been talking to dulles
he essentially took wolf's family
hostage back in germany and said you
better get your tail back here
and we're going to have a pretty serious
chat about what you've been up to
so with uh considerable trepidation wolf
went back to berlin
and got chewed out by himmler
and
kind of
their talk ended with
wolf being ordered to go see
hitler himself that evening
wolf left a very interesting account of
going to see hitler late in the war down
in the fjord bunker which was the
underground sort of fortress bomb
shelter that hitler lived in
and wolff kind of spun a story that was
part true in part lie he said yeah i've
been meeting with dulles he figured the
germans had figured that out
but he said it wasn't really to
surrender it was really to cut a good
deal for us some sort of
peace deal between germany and the
united states and he claimed that dulles
had the ear of roosevelt and thereby he
could communicate directly with
roosevelt
so hitler sort of calmed down and he
thought that maybe that was a good idea
and in the latter
months of the war that was kind of
hitler's main hope for how the war would
end was that the americans and the
soviets would have some sort of falling
out he really was never convinced that
the communists and the capitalists
could really get along for very long
so he sent wolfe back to italy wolf said
he was just happy to get home with his
head still on his shoulders
and
to begin
new negotiations with dulles
those talks sort of
dragged on for several weeks and there
are all sorts of
sort of misadventures and false starts
but they finally agreed a surrender
of german forces
which
took place on may 2. and dulles was
pretty
fired up about that
he had achieved quite a feat
fortunately a sort of a lot of the
accomplishment
diminished when the entire german army
in europe surrendered
five days later
but it still was meaningful
wolff
had no doubt treated american prisoners
of war
better than he would have and it refused
to destroy italian artworks or italian
factories because he was talking to
dulles and and it did end
fighting five days early and you know
probably saved hundreds if not thousands
of
american lives
dulles stayed on in germany
after the war he became the station
chief for the oss in wiesbaden which is
just up the rhine a little bit from
frankfort
um
but his heart really wasn't in it
he kind of disagreed with american
occupation policy the americans
after the war had laid down very strict
rules that basically barred anybody who
had been associated with the nazi party
from participating in occupation
government
and dulles really didn't agree with that
policy his prime concern as always was
the soviet union and he wanted to make
sure that germany really got back on its
feet and was stable politically and
economically and if you had to turn to
ex-nazis to achieve that that was
the price you had to pay i mean he once
said
that
you can't even make the trains run in
germany on time without the help of
ex-nazis
they'll spend a lot of time
sort of not really managing the staff
that was assigned to him
and most of his attention was given to
what he called the crown jewels
these were people who he had worked with
during the war he wanted to make sure
that they were well looked after
kolba who we saw a few minutes ago was
particularly um
well looked after he was given a car and
food rations and you know basically
nobody had a car in germany right after
the war so that was that was something
um
dulles eventually he left germany in the
fall of 1945 when the oss was disbanded
he returned to his law practice at
sullivan and cromwell in new york
and he still was pretty much living in
the past
other lawyers there said that he
remained uh very fixated on the war and
just spent as much time as possible
reminiscing with old friends who had
come by
he got very active in the council on
foreign relations and kind of used
that platform to argue for treating
germany well and not trying to punish it
excessively for the war
he also advised congress on establishing
a new intelligence service to replace
the oss and what eventually became the
cia
and of course he became the first
civilian director of the cia in 1953.
so that's that concludes my uh
prepared remarks i'd be happy to try and
answer any questions i guess if you want
to ask you need to make your way to a
microphone which is on
either side there's one over there
and one over there so
yes sir
what happened to mary bancroft
i'm glad you asked that question because
i have a bonus slide
for that very question
and that is mary there with her legs
crossed and she's sitting with clover
dulles who was dulles wife
and it turned out that clover came to
switzerlands and joined dulles while the
war was still on
and
dulles being dulles his wife
they didn't they had an unhappy marriage
i think it's safe to say and clover
sometimes kind of got in his hair so he
asked mary can you you know
become buddies with my wife and take
care of her which was a pretty bold move
but
mary volunteered and clover pretty
quickly clover was quite astute and she
figured out pretty quickly what had been
going on
she told mary you know
i i know what's been up to and i think
the quote was something like and i
approve
um
she and and mary became pals they both
were very interested in the uh jung and
studied
his writings
and in the closing dates of the war they
even took a tour sort of on the northern
border of switzerland to kind of look
across into germany and
mary wrote about their trip together and
you know all the horrible things they
could see in in germany
they actually remained friends um long
after the war mary moved to new york and
she
continued to
study jung she wrote some books
and
she wrote
the autobiography of a spy about her
experiences in the 1980s
but she was always i i felt
i wish i could have met her but she
seemed like a really interesting
character somebody was really
comfortable in her own skin and always
spoke her mind
anyone else
so the station chief
you know they mentioned you mentioned
the germans were outside
did people actually know his actual role
how how long did it take before
everybody said oh duh of course he's the
oss dude
that's a good question um
it didn't take them long to figure out
that he was in germany but there had
been a newspaper article that was
written in a swiss newspaper
shortly after dulles arrived and that
newspaper article said that this guy
ellen dulles is here he's kind of a
well-known diplomat
and the newspaper article said that he
was a special emissary from roosevelt
which was slightly different from
roosevelt's cover story
and
dulles was at first horrified that there
was a newspaper article about him
but he kind of realized pretty quickly
that you know if people want to believe
that i'll let them
and the germans bought that they wrote a
rather lengthy report
i think it was in january or february of
1943 just a few months after he arrived
saying that dulles was there and it had
a biography of him and they had found
some germans who had known him from
before the war and they said he's in
switzerland and he's just here on
roosevelt's behalf
and we think he's really most interested
in
the german economy you know gathering
intelligence about the german economy
and it really wasn't sort of
late very late in the war before they
kind of figured out that he was oss
um
they really sort of clung to this
mistaken identity they knew that he was
doing some espionage but they really
didn't know that much about his um his
network there was a
a report that the germans did after
valkyrie in the summer of 1944 and they
mentioned dulles as somebody who had
been working with the german resistance
so you know they they had a pretty good
idea with what he was about and what he
was up to but um
uh certainly
they were lacking a lot of the detail
how did how did dulles get the
information he was gathering back to the
united states so that they could take
advantage of it that
was a constant
problem
they had originally because switzerland
was surrounded by the germans and the
occupied territories italians on all
sides they originally experimented by
giving documents to diplomats from
neutral countries
who would smuggle it out of the country
through france you know to spain which
was neutral and they could fly it out
from there but those documents tended to
go missing from time to time
so that didn't work very well
they experimented they
would transmit some things just over the
telephone and they knew that the swiss
intelligence service was monitoring
their telephone lines
the swiss really monitored everybody
the swiss knew that there were a lot of
spies in their country
and they were kind of willing to look
the other way but they wanted to know
what everybody was up to and there were
people in the swiss intelligence service
who were pro-american
and there were some who were pro-german
and so you really couldn't transmit very
much secret information over the
telephone
um
so dulles used uh created a very simple
code that he would send things back and
forth on on by telegram
the problem was that the coding was
was always difficult and the swiss
helped him out quite a bit with that
there were quite a number of german
pilots and air crew who had been
found their way to switzerland which was
neutral maybe they had crashed along the
border and snuck into switzerland or
sometimes if a plane developed
mechanical trouble they would land in
switzerland
and the swiss wouldn't return them to
the u.s but they allowed them to stay in
their country
and dulles as i said mentioned during
the talk had some friends in swiss
intelligence and so they let the air
crews work with dulles on a lot of the
coding
of the
secret documents um
latter later in the war this was one of
the coolest things that they thought of
when they were getting a lot of
microfilm of secret documents from
germany they convinced a a railroad
engineer who went between leon france
and geneva
to build a special compartment in his
train
and it was kind of near the boiler and
so they would put microfilm or documents
in the secret compartment and it
actually had a little
lever on it and so if the train was ever
inspected the conductor could hit this
lever and whatever was in this
compartment would fall into the flames
of the of the boiler and be incinerated
and you could avoid detection
and so those documents would go to
france where it was met by members of
the french underground who bicycled it
down to the mediterranean
and they took it by boat
to a location it was eventually flown to
london where it was looked at and then
sent on to washington
but they did that really sort of for the
bigger
documents that they had that were
difficult to transcribe
and where they just wanted to send the
originals
aside from hitler's intuition with that
much resistance did you develop any
theories about why an assassination
attempt never was successful
it is
you know the guys in the resistance you
can't but marvel at how brave they were
because if you got caught and i have to
say almost all of them did at one point
or another you were
looking at a pretty grisly death um
but hitler he just it's inexplicable um
there was an individual that i talk
about in the book
by the name of gjorg elser who was in
1939 he invented a plot where he was
going to blow hitler up this
story kind of illustrates just how lucky
hitler was
he was going to blow up this beer hall
that hitler was speaking in
and the guy was ingenious he got a job
in a construction factory and
construction works and was able to steal
some dynamite
which he used for the bomb and he was a
carpenter and invented a
really accurate and sophisticated timing
device
and he knew that the date and time that
hitler was going to be speaking in this
beer hall and so he would go into the
beer hall at night
got hide in the bathroom tell everybody
left
and he would come out with his little
tool box and he carved out a kind of a
hollow in one of the support posts on
the the platform where hitler was going
to speak
he did this over several days
and put the bomb in there
everything worked perfectly
but on that particular night there was
bad weather in the munich area and
hitler's pilot said i don't think we can
fly back to berlin you better take the
train
so hitler called off his speech a little
bit early just
you know 10 or 15 minutes early
the bomb went off exactly as timed um
with a tremendous explosion and killed a
number of people when the roof collapsed
hitler would have been killed um but it
was just a matter of
bad weather there were i mean i could go
on and on about similar just
inexplicable
um twists of fate that that spared
hitler was incredible
anybody else
since there's nobody else one more
question
do you have a sense for if if the july
20th or any of the other plots against
hitler had succeeded would have that
haste in the end of the war
i think yeah i'm sure so
because the people who wanted to replace
hitler were very keen to end the war um
i think they probably despite the
protests from roosevelt and this is all
this is kind of the fun of history
playing the what if game but um um
i think that the americans if hitler had
been replaced and a new german
government came and said
let's let's quit this nonsense um it's
hard to an american you know to imagine
any american government to you know turn
too cold to shoulder to those kinds of
offers
um
you know it's nothing you know
it's hard to imagine otherwise that the
war wouldn't have ended much more
quickly
and just a follow-up thing do you think
it would have been something other than
unconditional surrender in that case
you know
there's a lot of theories that uh dulles
was kind of with a wink and a nudge was
telling the germans just that that it's
america's stated policy um that we will
not negotiate with you
but there was there's actually was a
document from a german source that the
claim that dulles had told him you know
you guys get rid of hitler and i'll see
that you guys are looked after
so
i think you know politically how could
you continue with the war if you had
people who were
you know saying hey we got rid of hitler
we hate him we want to be your friends
um you know how do you say no we're
going to fight you to the bitter end um
it's hard to imagine otherwise but
it's fun to talk about
okay well thank you so much everybody
enjoyed talking to you
[Applause]
and then folks just a reminder there is
a book signing one level up at the
archives bookstore 15 off on lecture day
so make sure
[Music]
it's just
here's a